a new program in Amsterdam is literally
paying alcoholics with beer to clean up
trash off the streets it's a privately
created program but the government is
funding some of it in exchange for
cleaning litter off the streets workers
get two beers before work at 9am two
beers at lunch two beers after work half
a packet of rolling tobacco so even if
you didn't have a tobacco problem before
you will have one out you do get a free
lunch which is nice 10 euros a day which
is about thirteen dollars and fifty five
cents so yet you could be an alcoholic
because of vodka or gin but you're just
getting beer according to this um right
I know we're gonna have a lot of funny
stuff on this but is there are they on
to something here that they're taking
these people and making them productive
even though they're using their
addiction which obviously is kind of
sick yeah but you know reading the story
a lot of time so people that are
addicted are going to be addicted no
matter what you do so it kind of gives
them something one guy said sure I know
I I'm an alcoholic but at least I have I
have a job now so it gives me some pride
um you know I commend them for trying to
do something yeah you know they tried to
do other programs where they up security
at the parks to clear out the drunks
just you know laying on the the park
benches and laying on the grass drinking
and being drunk all day well at least
now maybe they've gotten them down to
where we'll give them a couple beers and
they'll walk around and actually do
something instead of laying around all
day being a nuisance to the rest of
society um you know I don't know if it's
the greatest thing but I commend them
for doing something I don't I don't find
it that bad you know I'm not offended by
it too bad I mean maybe there there's
better ways but you know where is
somebody else making the better way or
coming up with a better idea i haven't
come up with a better idea so so but is
there no way to incentivize good
behavior you know we're just reinforcing
what they're doing yeah that is what
they're doing actually I mean they're
taking folks you have an addiction and
they're saying okay these other issues
are not working kicking you out of the
park means you just move to a different
place but actually paying you to clean
up your park and to have
job that you can give back to your
community seems to be working I mean the
proof is in the pudding and even if they
did pay them money or euros it's gonna
go they're gonna go take the money and
go right to the liquor store and buy the
beer themselves anyway so they're just
paying them they're just taking out the
money middle part and paying them and if
you don't smoke they're going to use
that tobacco is bartering I'm sure
they're going to barter with it but one
guy did say so there is a little bit of
good that comes from the story one guy
said well I usually drink hard liquor
but you know now I just drink a beer
right and so that's a little bit better
right and also when I looked at when you
when you read further about more about
this this particular program that they
have going you know one of the guys said
something that I thought was really
heartbreaking he's like you know I
guarantee you you look around at any of
the guys sitting around this table and
we all have our own little backpack of
misery that we carry around every day
this gives us a chance this gives us
gives us hope it gives us a path out of
this right but aren't we also then or
aren't they also then feeling that
backpack because we're in there still
enabling the action that they're trying
to be your weird you're now thinking of
a perfect society then we'd have no
alcoholics no drunks no heroin addicts
no coke users no marijuana attics I mean
that really is trying to make something
very clean that is never going to be you
know unless we really can completely
cure alcoholism or mental health issues
or drug addiction but that's not going
to go away anytime soon I don't I think
you're trying to make a nice little bow
that is not reality you know anymore it
also takes care of other ills for
example when you have heroin addicts or
given free methadone just to basically
you know stay off the streets and not
engage in criminal activity you know
that is an external benefit to this
particular policy that does come from
enabling these people so you know there
are I think trade-offs that come with
this if it's a policy that works and
actually helps these people you know
maybe move out of where they were and to
a place where they're actually
participating bad deal but it's better
than doing nothing yet do you think this
could ever work something like this
could ever work in the United States
because they matter right now
state-by-state leap weed is getting
legalized and I think in a couple years
it'll be probably legalized countrywide
and it'll be fine and everyone
oh that wasn't such a big deal sort of
like gay marriage Amsterdam obviously
has had marijuana legal for many many
years although it's actually a little
harder now to get than it used to be but
is this just the next natural step of
trying to deal with these vices so to
speak in sort of more mature ways
dealing with something in a more
practical pragmatic way that actually
accomplishes something no I don't think
we'll ever have that here sorry I don't
I know guys I don't have so many laws
well how bad of an alcoholic are you do
you make too much money for us to give
you free beer well you could be doing
this job and say there would be too many
problems and issues to just say okay
you're an alcoholic we'll go clean the
streets will give you pay that you would
have to fill out too much paperwork and
it would be too difficult I think we
have too many moralistic authoritarians
who want to punish people and they're
not actually interested in doing what's
better they're not interested in helping
they're not interested in making it
better they just want to punish them for
not acting and behaving in the way that
these people think they should behave
inactive and that that infuses all of
our politics as home it well it's
interesting i was talking to dr. drew
the other day and he said penitentiary
used to be penitence where we would take
them into our system if they broke the
law and you would reform them and in
rehabilitate input and bring them back
out and to be productive members of
society and now we just throw them in
prison and throw away the key yeah
that's as we and we have private prisons
and all kinds of other stuff for profit
which is completely bonkers but that's a
whole other topic now we will also try
to get to next week